your names and stuff
no ma'am no you're not going to decide
to outcome of this we will decide and
we'll let you know how everything's
gonna happen here okay shocking body
camera video shows the arrest of
self-proclaimed profit and
fundamentalist Church leader Samuel
Bateman after investigators found him
illegally transporting underage girls in
a trailer how old are you
how old are you 11.
it happened on August 28th in Flagstaff
Arizona authorities pulled over Bateman
after receiving multiple concerned calls
about his trailer white children are
being transported in a vehicle we're
getting calls about uh hands sticking
out of a vehicle out of the trailer
um so that is why we're contacting you
guys because it is unsafe for children
to be riding in a trailer Inside the
trailer investigators found three girls
ages 11 to 14 hiding the trailer had
makeshift seats and a porta potty inside
federal court documents say Bateman is a
leader in the fundamentalist Church of
Jesus Christ of the Latter-Day Saints or
flds the church known for practicing
polygamy is an offshoot of the modern
Latter-Day Saints Church local news
stations report Bateman has dozens of
followers and more than 20 wives who he
is accused of sexually abusing and
trafficking across state lines
about you
at this point he's detained right now
I don't know
okay I understand that but like he said
once we do our investigation we can
figure this out but body camera
the CERN for Bateman demanding he be
released
no ma'am no you're not going to decide
to outcome of this we will decide and
we'll let you know how everything's
gonna happen here okay the women can
also be heard saying they fear law
enforcement referencing the 2008 raid of
Warren jeffs's fundamentalist sect in
Texas
okay well and what city or state was
that in
well you're in Flagstaff Arizona right
now
um so what we will treat you uh we're
just trying to happen we are just trying
to figure this out right now Bateman was
charged with three counts of child abuse
and is being held in Florence Arizona
three adult women believed to be some of
Bateman's wives are also charged with
kidnapping and obstruction of justice
reporting for long crime Network I'm
Sierra Gillespie